j'accueille maintenant Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
bonjour
nous sommes le 6 juillet je suis à peu
près
j'ai l'impression d'être un carnivore
enfermé dans un bac à légumes
alors nouvelle principale de la semaine
les États-Unis nous espionnent waouh
et la nouvelle du siècle si le premier
squelette humain a été retrouvé en
Afrique on est sûr que c'est en France
qu'on va déterrer le premier squelette
de Bisounours
ici on y croyait pas c'était énorme mais
pourtant Obama quand il nous dit bonjour
il sourit et qui peut pas
humiliation suprême l'Allemagne et 7
fois plus espionnée que la France ça
c'est normal c'est normal on va pas très
bien ce qu'on peut pomper sur la France
c'est les 35 heures sudrive je sais pas
je pense que les USA quand ils nous
espionnent c'est pour se détendre quand
ils écoutent l'Allemagne ils ont
l'impression d'être sur France Info dès
qu'il passe sur la France et rires et
chansons
[Applaudissements]
politique toujours alors Hollande a
réagi avec autorité il a viré Delphine
bateau l'espionne descendu d'une
éolienne la Mata Hari du compost tout
cas François il a le sens du timing les
Français partent en vacances tout le
monde s'en fout de la politique et la
Raoul qui décide de montrer qu'il en a
dans quel but quand il est là comme ça
là puis virer bateau pour l'exemple le
gouvernement ressemble à un nid de
moustique et lui il bute la coccinelle
m'a vachement sensibilisé
parce qu'en fait chez moi il y a il y a
une poubelle verte c'est une poubelle
noire bon il y en a une autre avec un
trou où ça fait scling de enfin jamais
compris à quoi ça servait
ça doit être un peu de chant pour les
gens avec les pieds un peu long tout ça
fait je sais pas très bien
et jusque là je pensais qu'on pouvait
mettre que des trucs verts dans la
poubelle verte
mais en fait
non parce que Delphine bateau elle a
sensibilisé quoi
alors elle a été remplacée par Philippe
Martin ah ouais c'est un type très
c'est qui en fait
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde se paluge tu auras
l'écologie c'est important quoi c'est il
faut il y a jamais une grosse pointure
pour gérer le ministère de l'écologie
mais c'est en écologie ça me fait penser
à la bonne copine tu vois tout le monde
t'explique que c'est la femme idéale
mais personne veut la tirer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bref Egypte Egypte alors apparemment
maintenant le printemps arabe c'est une
fois par an
bah ça se comprend quand on sait qu'il y
a eu à peu près 100 agressions sexuelles
en quelques jours place tarir pourquoi
arrêter de manifester quoi c'est en fait
la place d'arrière c'est devenu un club
échangiste en plein air c'est
plus une révolution démocratique c'est
sexuelle c'est jouir sans entrave sous
le ni câble à tout enfin c'est très
alors résultat elle est manifestants ont
été entendus c'est-à-dire que l'armée a
dégagé le président Morty président qui
était à 32% d'opinion positives tu vois
c'est à ce genre de détails qu'on
remarque que l'armée française est
complètement sclérosée
[Applaudissements]
Front national Marine a perdu son
immunité parce que elle a parlé
d'occupation pour désigner des prières
de rue bon les prières de rue c'est vrai
que c'est un sujet qui excite les gens
c'est
moi j'ai un copain homo qui a un appart
juste au dessus de la rue en question tu
étais ravi quoi à chaque fois qu'il y
avait une prière de rue il allait jamais
à la terrasse sans son rouleau de
sopalin
[Applaudissements]
morale
Bernard Tapie est sorti de sa garde à
vue boum direct le 20h de gîte de France
2 agité après injuste c'est comme du
stretching après un match de boxe avec
Pujadas dans le rôle du jacuzzi puis
Jada s'il est mignon il a beau barboter
il est temps quand même
alors le pauvre qui a essayé d'arracher
des aveux à Bernard Tapie tout en
finesse Bernard Tapie vous avez été mis
en examen dans cette affaire
d'escroquerie en bande organisée est-ce
que c'est arbitrage a été un escroquerie
il croit qu'en 3 minutes il va lui
arracher l'aveu que les trois juges qui
l'ont mis sous séquestre n'ont pas
réussi à avoir
[Applaudissements]
tapis les magistrats moi la fin de
l'intervention je me suis dit vraiment
le pauvre quoi il a eu que 45 millions
de dommages intérêts Crédit Lyonnais
c'est vraiment des [ __ ]
divertissement de qualité quoi c'est
Nabilla avec un QI moi je suis
mercato télé on en parle en ce moment
télé sur plateau profitons-en alors en
sortant des studios de TF1 Claire Chazal
s'est ramassé un seau d'excrément à
travers la vitre de sa voiture elle a
réagi avec classe là regardez très vite
encore du taf
[Applaudissements]
sport lex footballeur Basile Boli est
condamné à deux ans de prison avec
sursis pour abus de confiance quand on
sait qu'il a joué à l'OM sous l'air
tapis prendre du sursis c'est un hommage
au patron
sentez le stress multiplie par deux le
risque cardiovasculaire c'est toujours
moins que la détente qui multiplie par 5
le risque de travailler dans la fonction
publique
alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine les
talibans ouvre un bureau au Qatar
bah oui forcément lourde ou Versailles
c'était un peu tangent c'est l'objectif
avouer c'est s'ouvrir au monde et
inviter les gens à mieux connaître les
talibans leur culture leur joie de vivre
c'est être taliban est tenté de séduire
à l'international c'est comme vouloir
choper sur adopte un mec en mettant pour
photo de profil la liste de TMST c'est
vraiment le truc alors pas belle la vie
et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu